c'est une situation inédite depuis la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 la
commission spéciale de l'assemblée
nationale sur les retraites a décidé de
balayer d'un revers de main les 22000
159 amendements déposés par l'opposition
plutôt que de modifier la réforme cette
surcharge d'amendements a finalement
bloqué l'adoption du projet en
commission selon des sources
parlementaires il n'est jamais arrivé
qu'une commission ne viennent pas à bout
des amendements déposés entre gâchis et
amertume les députés de tous les bords
ont reconnu leur frustration face à
l'interruption des travaux et finalement
personne n'est content sauf le
gouvernement puisque cela veut dire que
c'est la version du projet déposé par le
gouvernement qui saura donc examiné à
partir du 17 février sans que soient
pris en considération les changements
votés en commission
c'est un constat que j'établis avec
regret cela va sans dire
car depuis lundi dernier notre
commission spéciale a beaucoup travaillé
elle s'est réunie durant près de 75
heures à examiner 5566 amendements et
bien que nous ne soyons pas parvenus au
terme du projet de loi ses principaux
enjeux ont été abordés une décision qui
a provoqué un tollé au sein de la classe
politique et ce malgré un nombre record
d'amendements à seuls les 17 élus de la
france insoumise ont présenté 19 1350
cet amendement soit environ à 90% du
total
jean luc mélenchon a réagi ce soir la
charge du maquereau nisme contre les
retraites et mise en échec
l'examen du texte est interrompue à
l'article 26 sur soixante cinq que
compte la loi la commission spéciale a
permis des révélations décisive
la lutte continue sur tous les fronts
l'obstination de macron sera vaincu
parmi les autres amendements recensé
1148 venait des républicains 489 des
communistes 298 de l1 om 283 du ps 50 du
modem et enfin 28 de lui
i de leur côté les députés les
républicains dénoncent un fiasco
parlementaire c'est la politique par le
mépris mépris du parlement des
institutions des corps intermédiaires
des députés et des forces vives de la
nation ont dénoncé cette attaque
permanente envers les institutions et
cet irrespect du parlement dans la
majorité on fustige l' avalanche
d'amendements provoquée par la france
soumise
l'opposition elle rejette en bloc le
calendrier parlementaire est la
commission justifie également son choix
par le fait que plusieurs amendements
seraient identiques
les trois groupes de gauche ont décidé
de taper fort le ps pcf et la france 1
soumises ont promis de présenter une
motion de censure et une motion
référendaire
emmanuel macron quant à lui ch a exhorté
les députés de la majorité à vendre
cette réforme afin de faciliter son
adoption définitive avant l'été
pendant ce temps le mouvement social lui
se poursuit avec cinq syndicats qui
appellent à une journée morte au rang
des transports parisiens
le lundi 17 février et une journée
interprofessionnelle de grève fixée par
l'intersyndicale
au 20 février